Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d', Seita.
This program is designed to help you become the native maestro...
...under such great weather and beautiful view today.
Today's Maestro Hook is about the word "just" in Japanese and English.
Japanese people use the word "just" a lot.
For example,...
Or for example,...
Or,...
In English, the word "just" means "only", so we don't really use it that much.
For example,...
...is seven o'clock sharp.
Also,...
Idea is already just an idea, so you say, "Oh, it's an idea." No "just".
And....
...is maybe perfect for me.
But we don't really say that either as a perfect match.
So, don't use the word "just" and use the word that's perfect for the sentence.
And today's Maestro Menu.
Today's Maestro Menu is about the perfect words to say in a perfect moment.
For example,...
It rings a bell.
Oh, yeah! It rings a bell.
Oh! It just rings a bell.
It rings a bell.
Also, one more. There's another one called,...
Off the top of my head.
This is off the top of my head.
Oh! So, I have an idea off the top of my head.
Alright, Maestro Lines.
Do you know the company, Sony?
Oh, yeah! It rings a bell.
Anybody have any good plans?
Oh! Actually, I have an idea, but it's just off the top of my head.
Is that okay?
Yeah, yeah, please say it.
OK.
Alright! So, from the top of a building, see you guys next week.
Bye-bye!